et pour en parler nous sommes nous avec
caroline mécary avocate et benjamin amar
porte parole cgt val de marne on l'a
entendu d'ailleurs
bonjour moi j'aime à marc bonjour
également caroline mécary merci d'être
avec nous alors les premiers chiffres de
la mobilisation un parisienne ils nous
viennent des syndicats exclusivement le
ministère de l'intérieur ne s'est pas
encore exprimé 20000 à paris selon les
syndicats que dit ce chiffre alors on
parle d'une mobilisation plutôt
clairsemé en général dans les dépêches
le 49-3 vraiment raviver la mobilisation
selon vous à benjamin a marre mais je
pense que certains commentateurs ferait
bien de revenir dans le monde réel le
49-3 il date de samedi on est mardi vous
allez il ya un certain nombre de
secteurs d'abord vous faut faire des
déclarations avant de se mettre en grève
c'est marrant ce qui à certains
éditorialistes qui s'empressent je
prends pas de personnes dont les maris
fils et les premiers à applaudir
contient par exemple le service minimum
donc bien évidemment quand on est sur
une sur une initiative aussi réactive
bien sûr que tout le monde peut pas se
mettre en grève et que encore une fois
c'est des gens qui ne se sont pas
mobilisés sans doute depuis clovis mais
qui n'ont jamais fait grève depuis
vercingétorix mais dont la dans le monde
réel du capitalisme du 21e siècle
oui bien sûr les initiatives elles sont
fatalement moins massive
pour autant il ya quand même
effectivement des dizaines de milliers
de personnes qui se sont mobilisés alors
que la prochaine date de mobilisation
c'est celle du 31 mars
donc bien sûr que le 49-3 scandalise et
ils scandalise ceux qui se sont arrangés
pour être au gré vers manille pour d'huy
et bien au delà la question surtout et
c'est celle qui vous intéresse et qui
intéresse tout le monde
est ce que aujourd'hui ces mobilisations
peuvent vraiment pesé sur un
gouvernement qui a l'air complètement
déterminé
à passer en force clairement caroline
mécary l'hermance un gouvernement qui
passe en force après deux ans de pseudo
concertation parce qu'il n'y en a pas eu
bien qu'il ait été étrillé par le
conseil d'état qui a rendu un avis qui
dit vrai véritablement que ce projet de
loi n'est ni fait ni à faire une étude
d'impact qui montre que les calculs sont
un sincère etc etc
mais il n'en démord pas il veut si vous
avez vu vous des études d'impact très
précises ah oui alors là ah oui sur la
sur les professions non non oui mais
justement là il y en a pas prenez par
exemple voilà c'est comme ça se finira
question parce que c'est bien l'étude
d'impact est non seulement un sincère
mais elle est incomplète et lacunaire
vous ne trouverez pas notamment un
exemple type de femmes avec des enfants
donc réellement nous savons que ce
gouvernement est dans une logique qui
est une logique dogmatique
c'est à dire en ligne de mire les
retraites ne doivent pas peser plus de
14% du pib très bien et donc comme dans
la conférence du financement
on a appris que l'ignorer absolument
aucune possibilité de discuter sur une
éventuelle augmentation de la cotisation
patronale qui va payer ce sont les
travailleurs qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
dans le public ou dans le privé où que
ce soit des travailleurs indépendants
donc dès samedi soir à l'annonce du 49-3
iain des mobilisations spontanées dans
toute la france et en l'espace de même
pas deux jours il a fallu monter la
manifestation d'aujourd'hui mais y'a pas
que les manifestations qui vont peser
il y à de si je prends simplement les
avocats les avocats puisqu'ils vont
utiliser il vaut utiliser les armes
qu'il connaît c'est à dire la parole et
le litige judiciaire juridique donc ça
va être des actions en responsabilité
contre l'état ça va être les discussions
avec les sénateurs parce que là le
projet de loi certes dont on connaît pas
le contenu quand même on ne connaît pas
le contenu sans il a juste c'est un vrai
c'est un vrai sujet donc il va passer au
sénat les sénateurs ils ont un pouvoir
réellement et ensuite au final on ira
peut-être jusque devant fin même sûr on
ira devant le conseil constitutionnel
mais les batailles elles ne sont perdus
que lorsqu'on cesse de les mener donc
nous sommes debout et nous sommes contre
cette réforme pas que les avocats les
travailleurs les 20 salariés
fonctionnaires sont aussi impactés par
ce n est pas bon mais d'abord
effectivement il faut poser clairement
cette ce cette réalité là le bout
moment à défaut de convaincre puisque
sur la question de la bataille de
l'opinion comme disait raoul volfoni
dans les tontons flagueurs ils se sont
fait exploser façon puzzle
c'est à dire que maintenant plus
personne au sein de sa majorité n'ose
parler de la bataille de l'opinion ils
ont renoncé à cela les sondages sont
très claires deux tiers des français
effectivement sont opposés à la réforme
deux tiers des français exigent un
référendum sur cette réforme et non pas
1 49 3 et donc à défaut de convaincre
cette majorité elle essaye de vaincre
donc elle essaye de vous êtes offensée
ce on a du mal à comprendre
effectivement cette motivation du
gouvernement un projet politique
risquant l'objet en l'occurrence je
pense que il faut il faut il faut relier
cette réforme au reste des basses
besognes d'emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron je le rappelle après un an de
gilet jaune avait dit il y aura un volet
2 dans mon quinquennat et ce sera un
volet social
écoutez cet été on a eu la 112 la pire
réforme de l'unedic pour stigmatiser les
chômeurs et là maintenant on se coltine
la réforme la plus rapide sur les ondes
se dire tiens ça peuvent plus faire des
émules l'assurance chômage est passé
emmanuel mais je pense à rien je pense
que la conséquence a été très clair je
verse et il l est comme le nez au milieu
du visage
emmanuel macron et le lac est le plus
élevé du patronat depuis 1945
à côté de lui même nicolas sarkozy
apparaît pour un amateur
donc il est très bon le conte politique
pour emmanuel macron sera terrible mais
attention les mobilisations ne sont pas
terminées on n'en a pas fini avec cette
bataille je peux vous le dire moi qui
suis au milieu de mes camarades je peux
vous assurer qu'on en a pas fini sur
cette bataille là caroline mécary mais
non mais très clairement on est dans un
projet politique et le démantèlement de
l'état social toujours moins d'état
et c'est dans cette logique là et là où
on atteint si j'allais dire la limite
c'est qu'on est dans le cadre d'une
constitution qui permet à un homme avec
son premier ministre de décider pour
l'ensemble des français et donc c'est on
est on est vraiment à l'opposé de ce que
devrait être un débat démocratique et on
vient de voir avec la mise en place du
49 3 comment y compris
au sein de l'assemblée nationale il est
confisqué et comment est-ce qu'on peut
il me comment est ce qu'un président
peut imaginer qu'une réforme comme celle
des retraites qui remet en cause
l'héritage du conseil national de la
résistance qui avait quand même pour
objet d'instituer une solidarité entre
ses actifs et ceux qui cessent de
travailler puissent être discuté en
l'espace de même pas trois semaines à
l'assemblée nationale il ya des choix
qui sont faits qui sont de paris mais en
force
parce que ces gens là iront aussi
l'opposition la france insoumise et
communistes en déposant un amendement
sur abonnement de plus 40 et non mais
attendez on va vous réveillez vous et
moi la question il ya des gens qui sont
fondamentalement contre ce projet et qui
voit la pensée que l'opposition est
peut-être allé trop loin et a fourni une
excuse a fourni une excuse parfaite au
gouvernement reste un prétexte
très sincèrement c'est un prétexte il
suffisait en réalité il avait le prénom
mais si le gouvernement avait été de
bonne foi si ce parlement avait été de
bonne foi
d'abord on aurait commencé par
réellement faire de la concertation et
non pas faire semblant
ensuite on aurait tenu compte de l'avis
du conseil d'état qui est quand même un
conseil d'état ce ne sont pas des
affreux gauchistes sont des gens qui ont
l'habitude de peser leurs mots et qui
disent très clairement que ce projet en
fait n'est ni fait ni à faire
on n'aurait pas eu une étude d'impact
qui fait mille par mille pages qui est
du d'un manque de rigueur absolue c'est
à dire qu'on aurait eu un gouvernement
qui aurait temporisé qui aurait écouté
qui au lieu de sortir le 49-3 aurait dit
bon ok j'entends je comprends on va
remettre ça à plat on suspend la suspend
l'art et la réforme et on voit quels
sont les points d'achoppement
mais comme en réalité le projet
politique ça reste les retraites pas
plus de 14% du pib
et comme on veut pouvoir le faire très
tranquillement on va mettre en place la
retraite à points avec la valeur d'un
point qui n'est même pas indexé sur un
indice qu'on connaît c'est quand même
absolument invraisemblable ben voilà on
en est là ben gérard alors lui edouard
philippe il essaye de rassurer en disant
on a tenu compte des points
oui de l'opposition etc c'est ce qui dit
elle alors débuter alors je vais
répondre à ça que je vais aussi répondre
parce que vous avez pointé que c'est
très important
oui mais alors vous savez chez les
maquereaux nist on est comme chez les
aurois lien c'est à dire que c'est comme
dans 1984 les mots veulent dire l'
inverse de leur sens savez je crois que
c'est monsieur est ce que c'est l'europe
qui trace un ch'ti qui a dit qu'on avait
un 49,3 de rassemblement voyez vous on
va bientôt inventé les bonbons dentaire
et la crinière des choses alors été
c'est très simple par rapport à ce que
vous avez pointé
est-ce qu'on peut d'abord rappeler quand
même très étonnant monsieur le maire et
monsieur macron nous disait à l'automne
on a énormément de temps on a beaucoup
de temps on prendra tout le temps là
maintenant c'est la course contre la
montre je rappelle me semble que c'est
marcello qui a dit si on avait continué
à ce rythme eh bien on aurait mis deux
mois et demi à boucler le débat c'est
trop deux mois et demi pour parler des
retraites
je rappelle juste à titre de mémoire que
au moment où on a parlé de la
privatisation tf1 on a eu un débat
parlementaire de deux mois je rappelle
que le rythme des amendements lors de la
deuxième semaine était de 90 amendements
par jour ce qui est un très bon rythme
en réalité pendant ce débat on n'a pas
fait que parler des adverbes comme le
dit la macro ni avec ses éléments de
langage on m'a parlé par exemple de deux
il ya des lièvres qui ont été levés par
exemple sur la question de la valeur du
point
savez la reconnaissance et l émotion des
salaires et qui maintenant se rassurent
un indice fumeux qu'il reste à
construire
et comme par hasard c'est pas le 49 3 et
on pas comme par hasard il arrive alors
que les régimes spéciaux ont été traités
et que la abords des arrivées des sujets
sur lequel la macro ni est en difficulté
sur le financement parce que j'ai dit il
ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes sur le
financement est également sur la valeur
du point
c'est une immense manipulation cette
histoire justement la conférence de
financement caroline mécary avant
d'interroger le principal intéressé du
soir la cgt a claqué la porte
aujourd'hui après fo hier est ce que
c'est une bonne solution de claquer la
porte est ce parce qu' edouard philippe
a prévenu si on trouve pas d'accord il
va le faire passer son âge pivot donc
est ce que vous le craignez
désormais les nord je crains rien du
tout je pense que les syndicats en
raison de ne pas vouloir être dans cette
mascarade d'être l'alibi d'un
gouvernement qui de toute façon a déjà
décidé c'est à dire pourquoi les
syndicats ont claqué la porte tout
simplement parce que pour edouard
philippe il était clair que impossible
de toucher à la question la cotisation
patronale
pourtant l'augmentation de la cotisation
patronale de croiser si je ne me trompe
pas de 0 3% permet de financer
en réalité les retraites de manière
indolore et donc à partir du moment où
on vous dit c'est pas il n'y a pas de
discussion sur cette cotisation
eh bien je pense que les gens ont raison
il ya d'autres manières de financer bas
jamais à marle le mot de la fin désolé
ça arrive très vite et c'est très simple
et vous n'aviez pas le choix vous vous
sentiez nous sommes venus d'abord on va
couper court tout de suite à l'idée
qu'il ya convient on fait la politique
de la chaise vide on est venu avec un
économiste spécialiste de la question
michael zemmour on a présenté il a
présenté toutes les propositions de
financement alternative et solidaire que
nous avons sauf que c'est clairement
vous savez c'est comme dans le film de
de jacques tati il ya des roues ya des
sens interdits partout et on nous dit
voilà bien bienvenue dans la discussion
mais c'est une plaisanterie on a donc
écrit à mai à un courrier à edouard
philippe pour le dire répondez à nos
propositions
autrement ça sert à rien il ne nous
répond pas il est hors de question pour
eux effectivement d'accepter autre chose
que de la sueur du sang des larmes et
des sacrifices pour les travailleurs eh
ben on claque la porte ça fait deux ans
et demi que mes camarades de la cgt se
coltine ce simulacre de négociation et
si bête ndiaye il y encore quelques
semaines
oser dire que la cgt faisait la
politique de la chaise vide alors ça
fait deux ans et demi qu'on se coltine
ce calvaire
donc maintenant la mascarade ça suffit
on claque la porte et il était bien
temps merci en tout cas oui désolé on
arrive à la 70 milles avocats qui sont
en grève
ce ne sont pas des idiots c'est bien
parce qu'il n'y a absolument aucune
avancée ni pour eux ni pour lison en les
arrosant régulièrement il a expliqué je
le sais bien mais dont messi vous c'est
vous dire que les gens ne font pas grève
pour le plaisir
c'est qu'il ya de vraies raisons c'est
bien parce qu'il n'y a personne n'a dit
ça y est j'ai joué je me permets de lui
je pense que c'est vraiment important
merci en tout cas caroline mécary
benjamin a marre d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france